hi everyone jeff loretta here uh with
your quick weather update on those ones
that we've been talking about uh from
earlier today they have now started to
materialize uh especially coming from
the north or northern valley that's my
location right now located up in the
northwest part of las vegas the reason
we're up here is because those winds are
front really coming from the north
we're seeing some sprinkles outside
right now we anticipated that too
because we showed you those showers
earlier
mainly sprinkles at this point not going
to last all night you can probably hear
it maybe see it kind of hitting my hat
here i'm balding up because these
northern winds tend to bring in colder
colder air along with it that's why the
huge temperature drop expected for
tomorrow today wasn't too bad but with
this cold front passing through your
numbers are going to drop even more a
lot of people jumping on right now i
want to show you the winds that are
kind of what they've done
look at these webs so if you saw my
tweet earlier we did see gus
up to 46 at
the mid-40s for north las vegas also uh
in the
it really blowing up mid-40s in
centennial hills right now um
here's a look at my uh
my wheelchair got moved over
to the strong winds and they continue to
blow still at this hour so we wanted to
give a hub a heads up on that follow me
on twitter because that's what we'll be
uh tweeting about the gus throughout the
evening we've got an entire news crew
that's all spread out all across the
strip and they were giving me updates as
well
on the window
where the wind's up higher aloft will
tend to be higher too let me know what
you guys are seeing all right so uh
cheryl also to mention those wins in
north las vegas
yes we are actually watching uh the
fireworks on the strip all right because
there is a
threshold
they can't or say they can't light the
fireworks of course we're hoping with
the arrival of these winds earlier
that the winds will subside a little
more
of course that is going to be up to um
those fireworks will go off at midnight
uh what i'm told though is that they've
got
barriers kind of blocking the wind where
the mortars are at so hopefully they'll
still be able to light off those
fireworks but if you're going to be out
about tonight remember to bundle up like
it's the dead of winter okay because
it's better to be
warm than uncomfortably cold so layer up
like crazy
your hats can blow away and i'm wearing
mine right now so keep that in mind
you're gonna be out about and uh make
sure you you bundle up big time because
the windshield readings will be in the
30s for tonight
so we've been talking
to you
mobile jumping on east side as bad says
george pat watching diana omg
so yes we knew these ones were going to
happen about yesterday
in those mid to high 40s right now and
some areas are just seen those gusts in
the 30s which is still quite high
hopefully again those winds will subside
a little more later tonight by midnight
still expected to be windy and gusty no
matter what but we're hoping that the
peak winds really are going to happen
now or soon before we get on later on
the evening again don't forget to watch
us on eight news now we've got full
coverage my good friend michael yo is
hosting this year and we've got our
cameras spread around all over the las
vegas stream again gusty winds out